- We'll divide the room up
so, everyone gets a fair go.
You've put your hand ...
If you got a hand up in
your very polite way,
and you're looking at
me with the kind of ...
Oh, you're German, okay.
(audience laughs)
So, what would you like a
rap about, my German friend?
- [Woman] Flannels.
- You're not the German, though, are you?
(audience laughing)
Don't just fucking take over
the German, that's their job.
That's theirs.
(audience laughing)
Now it is my go first.
What would you like a rap about?
The moon landing?
(audience laughing)
The Germans don't have
a space program do they?
No, they wanted one, didn't they?
You know what happened with
all the good German scientists?
The Americans took them like don't worry
we won't mind what you did as long
as you get us to the moon.
Genuinely happened, it's really worrying.
The moon landing, maybe the moon landing
from a German perspective,
you said flannel?
(audience laughing)
And that's fine you
mean like a face cloth,
or you mean like the
plaid shirt they wear?
The face cloth, okay, cool.
I mean I feel bad we got two suggestions
from the same table
but German moon landing
and flannel is good let's
give you guys over here,
some free reign, what do you
want to hear a rap about?
- [Man] Carlisle.
- What?
- Carlisle.
(audience laughing)
Oh, didn't you get enough
attention from Steven earlier?
(audience laughing)
Where the fuck is Carlisle?
It's on the coast, how near Hull is it?
- [Man] The other side.
- The other side?
Oh, it's on the ...
Oh okay, yeah that makes sense.
Oh yeah, you stop there like between
Penrith and the Lakes right?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Yeah the only way I know it is
the train station where I stop, cool.
Carlisle, flannel, German moon landing.
Have you got a hand up, yeah?
- [Man] Onomatopoeia words.
- Onomatopoeia words do you have
a favorite onomatopoeia word?
An onomatopoeia word is
a word that's like ...
You know the word itself
sounds like boom or splash.
It's basically English lesson bullshit,
that really doesn't make sense.
(audience laughing)
What?
- [Man] Go with bang.
- Go with bang, okay, the
onomatopoeia word, bang,
Carlisle, flannel, German moon landings.
Let's kinda go to you guys, over here.
What do you want a rap about?
- [Man] Millennials.
- Millennials, you have the pitch of voice
that makes me think you are a millennial.
Is that the case?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, what's your favorite
part of being a millennial?
- [Man] Loneliness.
(audience laughing)
- If we were in America I'd be worried
you'd be about to shoot
up the place right now.
(audience laughing)
Okay the loneliness of millennials,
Carlisle, flannel, the
German moon landing,
and the onomatopoeia word, bang.
I might take an extra
one because I feel like
the Carlisle section of the
rap is gonna be very short.
(audience laughing)
What's that one?
- [Audience Member] Woodlouse.
- Hoodlums, what'd you say?
Woodlouse, okay, it's an animal
but it's a real specific niche one.
Okay, I'll take that, cool
that's six suggestions.
That's one more than I usually take,
but like I said Carlisle
might get a waylaid a bit.
Cool, this then, lovely
people in the Brian comedia,
a little treat for you guys,
a little Christmas gift.
Little thing called a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on those suggestions.
Suggestions once more,
flannel, German moon landing,
Carlisle, the onomatopoeia word bang,
the loneliness of millennials,
and woodlouse or woodlice.
You may need to remind me of these.
It's gonna be a freestyle, it's made up.
It's not written, it's not
scripted, and don't worry
it won't be any near as
atrociously, embarrassingly
toe-curlingly bad, as you
are expecting it to be.
(audience laughing)
You seem very unconvinced but
let's have some fun with this.
If we can drop that beat good sir.
Let's show'em how we do.
(somber piano music)
Did you say how is he gonna do this?
♪ Like this yeah, don't ask questions, ♪
♪ I spit in advice and in the bottom ♪
♪ of my garden under stone the woodlice, ♪
♪ woodlouse from the garden
soil into my house. ♪
♪ I say, deal with it,
I'm asking my spouse. ♪
♪ I'm scared of all the creepy crawlies, ♪
♪ I get a little glass ♪
♪ I put it on paper out to the grass, ♪
♪ the woodlouse pill
bug, curls to a sphere. ♪
♪ I flick it like a boogie
it's no longer near ♪
♪ They live under damp
wood, in the forest. ♪
♪ Let me move over and I apologize. ♪
♪ To anybody who's from Carlisle ♪
♪ I've never visited there,
and never will for a while. ♪
♪ It's on the west side of the country, ♪
♪ if I'm in hiding you
might hunt me down, ♪
♪ but I'm never in that town. ♪
♪ It's really, really shitty. ♪
♪ Is it a town, a
village, or even a city? ♪
♪ I'll never visit it,
so I'll never know, ♪
♪ if you're on holiday, then never go. ♪
♪ Carlisle, has it got
a lot of vehicles? ♪
♪ Bang, bang, yeah it's
a word that I adore. ♪
♪ I love it, when a bullet
comes out the gun, ♪
♪ it makes a loud noise
suggesting you better run. ♪
♪ Onomatopoeia is when
the word sounds like, ♪
♪ the letters on the page,
upon the words found. ♪
♪ Splash, ching, blink,
yay are the other ♪
♪ onomatopoeic words I can say. ♪
♪ I've got a stiff grip on
it, I loosen the handle. ♪
♪ Put the water from the tap,
on a nice thick flannel. ♪
♪ I rub it on my face
with some apricot scrub, ♪
♪ so hard with the motion I get
blood drawn from the pores, ♪
♪ My advice is use a flannel when ♪
♪ you wash your face, tonight. ♪
♪ Because the exfoliation
motion of the fibers, ♪
♪ gets all the of the dirt inside there. ♪
♪ It comes out, yeah,
out of your face there, ♪
♪ leaving pores open like a moon crater. ♪
♪ Did you have a hand
in, the moon landing? ♪
♪ Any Germans would
have an understanding, ♪
♪ they say, "Yeah we've
wished for so long, ♪
♪ to be like Buzz Aldrin and
Armstrong and Micheal Collins, ♪
♪ but no we never got there
Apollo into sky, yeah America! ♪
♪ If he had the Empire after the war, ♪
♪ we would be up there in
Apollo one through four. ♪
♪ The Russians took over with Gagarin, ♪
♪ we were all the Germans
we were just starving. ♪
♪ Having to pay reparations,
to you, horrible. ♪
♪ Forget about World War II." ♪
♪ But that's okay I'm in my couch, ♪
♪ feeling homely, in my apartment,
but I still feel lonely. ♪
♪ I try and call my friends
to come round here, ♪
♪ but the problem is that social media ♪
♪ has made us more connected
and more separated. ♪
♪ A self-loathing
millennial, so frustrated. ♪
♪ Yeah I feel like giving up the ghost, ♪
♪ and lonely as I eat my avocado toast. ♪
♪ Oh it's so hard, yes look at my face. ♪
♪ We ruined everything
Facebook and MySpace. ♪
♪ Ketchup on the side of our plate. ♪
♪ If you're a millennial,
then you got no mate. ♪
♪ Why, because you whine
all the God damn time. ♪
♪ Saying I am angry, I put it online. ♪
♪ Admittedly that is a
little bit of spit, ♪
♪ I'm a millennial and lonely
too, a fucking hypocrite yeah. ♪
(audience cheers loudly)